ray dalio
finally says i have some bitcoin this is
a coin desk
story concerns about a looming global
debt crisis have taken the world's top
hedge fund manager from doubting bitcoin
to dabbling in it ray dalio said the us
dollars on a verge of devaluation on a
level last seen in 1971 and that china
has threatened the greenback's
role as the world's reserve currency in
such an environment bitcoin with its
gold-like properties like
looks increasingly attractive as a
savings vehicle said dalio out of all
the people whose firm
started 2021 with 10.9 billion dollars
in assets
under management making it the world's
largest hedge fund 101 billion dollars a
manager my apologies not 10.1
100 billion under management and he said
i have some bitcoin dalio volunteered in
the middle of an interview with coindesk
chief content officer michael casey
dalio's off the cuff remark to coindesk
about owning some bitcoin represents the
closest thing
to an endorsement from him to date
nonetheless in the same conversation he
reiterated
his concern that government's fearing
competition from bitcoin to
state monetary system could crack down
on its owners bitcoin's greatest risk
is its success dalio caution gerard
man who am i to doubt ray dalio but if
the governments could have done anything
about bitcoin they would have done it
already do you think so yeah
you think so absolutely so you think if
they could have they would have already
done that that's your position
yeah the more i've i'm huge in the
crypto i'm massive in the crypto i'm a
big big fan i got into
it about four or five years ago and i
got to give a uh
a shout out a plug to my uh antagonistic
america podcast
i had a crypto expert one of the very
first miners in america eric gallison on
yeah and he was explaining to me
blockchain and exactly what it would
take to actually mess with with bitcoin
at this point
with over 100 million users worldwide
somebody would have to hack
into over 51 million different
individual servers across nations it
would it would take
for that to take place it would take
like a worldwide government like the
only way like bitcoin could possibly be
um you know fraud defrauded essentially
or really
ethereum even more so that could
possibly be defrauded would be
if let's say you know china ends up
winning the world and they take over the
entire world
and then they'd be able to go and get
each of those hundred plus million
servers and that would
individually have to do that and that
would assume that then they took
control of all of the satellites they
have all the cloud space
it it's a functional impossibility
really to do it
i i know um i i know your boy dan pena
may disagree
with this but uh i am all in on the
crypto future
and i think it's not really what what
the banks say look at what the banks
have done over the last
six months look at how they've entered
they they have etfs they have they're
doing crypto uh
uh buys in their hedges and stuff like
that now don't worry about what they say
worry about what they do and ray dalio
says i have some bitcoin i bet you
that's something when he says something
what do you think that sum is he says
have some bitcoin how much do you think
sum is to rate value
he's worth 20 20 plus he's the kind of
guy that says some bitcoin he might have
10 million dollars in bitcoin that's
some bitcoin to ray dalio
so so so so you think it's a 10 million
dollar i don't know i'm just saying
what do you think some is to him a guy
worth 20 what is some i think it's an
increasing
ever increasing amount so it is it is do
you think it's more less than 10 million
more more than 10 million more than 50.
okay so 10 or 50 million dollars it
might not even be 10 million
okay what would what what's one percent
of his net worth first of all
if somebody wanted to go find out how
much bitcoin he has somebody could
actually dig in and find out how much
bitcoin
did you see that they found buzzfeed
found joe biden's venmo speaking of
buzzfeed found joe biden not to get off
topic here
but let's get off topic it took buzzfeed
the
gender studies uh majors at buzzfeed
yeah
10 minutes to find our president's
venmo account and his 150 friends
how much was in it what was the deal it
was a public venmo account
and it had the people who was paying him
and who wasn't and then they asked the
white house
to comment and they took it down they
took his pla so it was his
like could you if these people right wow
so so again
we're talking about worried about
bitcoin but well the governments are
going to manipulate bitcoin
why would you worry about the president
united states there's a public venmo
that that that
you know he slapped yeah he's slapping
so starbucks barista
back to you you don't think the
government is going to come in and try
to regulate i think they've tried the
bitcoin at all you think it's done i
think they've tried out of your mind
michael how do you regulate an
international currency how do you
regularly
figure it out they're trying they can't
so that's it they're they're done you
said that they're not going to regulate
anymore and it's over
you can't beat them buy them they're
going to they're going to tie into it
but
here's here's the thing here's the thing
so for me if you think about it here's
ray dalio
if if you're saying they can't i've been
saying the same thing for years about
bitcoin cryptocurrency i've been saying
the same thing i'm saying
technology great it's going in that
direction phenomenal there's nothing you
can do about it that's here to stay
and i will never bet against the private
sector on the government
i i get that but i will also never bet
against the government sector to want to
regulate
anything they can get their hands off
anything they can get their hands on and
the way they do it is
they can do it through how many if they
want to control
uh uh like right now for example one of
the things that's coming up right now is
the fact that how
biden's talking about we shouldn't be
driving all uh cars that are what gas
gas cards right 460 gas in in california
when you sent me out there
exactly so 460 gas per gallon when you
go to california and this was just what
couple days or two
three days ago right so for them you
know what the government can do if they
really wanted to can they raise taxes to
tend
to raise uh gas to ten dollars a gallon
can they do that
government can the government do that
yeah i mean if they want to go can the
government do that they can restrict
supply they can restrict supply what
else can they do
what else can they do taxes they can
raise taxes what else can they do
the government can dictate which way you
spend your money if you have to look at
taxes and the government has a
compensation plan
whatever way they adjust the
compensation plan we as consumers
we as citizens we respond to whatever
tax plan they come up with okay so if
they don't want
us to go out there and spend money
buying gas because
they want us to drive electrical cars
you know they can
increase it to 10 bucks a gallon then
what happens behavior changes
so regulating bitcoin or cryptocurrency
isn't saying
we're watching you they can add the
dumbest taxes
on it to do whatever they can to control
it their way of regulating
isn't the same as regulating other
products we're not talking about like
you know back in the days joseph kennedy
said hey you guys are selling stocks
you guys are selling mutual funds here's
what we're doing uh fdr brings joseph
kennedy because joseph kennedy is the
one that manipulated the market the
great whole you know the whole 1929
crisis that took place he's i want you
to come and help me out here says you
know what here's what we're going to be
doing moving forward anybody that wants
to sell
any kind of securities and you're
touching cash you got to do fingerprints
what are you talking about
you guys got to drive down people drove
down to new york to get fingerprinting
to be able to sell stocks and bonds and
mutual funds right
back in the days you know people are
still doing fingerprinting today no
one's touching cash
but if you get securities license you
still got to do fingerprinting this
isn't about the kind of regulation
that maybe you're thinking about i think
the regulation that they could do
is very creative one could be heavy-duty
taxes
it's just a thought it just depends on
what like for instance
is it a security is it a is it a
currency is it
a store of value is it a commodity
whatever category it's going to fall in
it's going to get regulated by something
whether it's the sec
or finra whoever regulates uh
commodities
like to that point you just say that
they're not going to do any regulation
ever
that's not what i said because i want to
be very clear i want to be very clear
that's not what i'm saying
i agree with both of you that they are
going to try they have been trying
part of this capital gains increase is
specific to
crypto earnings but there's there's
first of all it
the retail investor is not in crypto
deep less than one percent of the
population owns crypto right now and
look at the valuation
again it's only 10 years in look at the
value of this
it has no tangible value you're not
buying things you're not using things on
an every day
and look at the price so in 10 years
when five percent of the population has
crypto and you're able to go into a
store and use it think of what the price
is going to be
so if they want to do sales tax on
crypto once it's a tangible currency i
can understand that they're going to try
to get their bite
but they're doing that now they're
trying to do it through capital gains
and what what's happened is a secondary
market has popped up real smart people
aren't selling their crypto and taking
that capital gains losses that's right
we're taking loans off of them said that
pam leonardo said most crypto guys they
don't sell they keep ninety percent of
their guys they're not selling because
that's when you pay your taxes on course
capital
i take loans off of my crypto so there's
there's a secondary exchange where you
can literally put your crypto in
and then you take a loan off your crypto
and you pay it back and you keep your
crypto so i'm able to extract value for
it
while keeping it right and i don't pay
the capital gains on that
that's a secondary market that evolved
you have people in this
particular industry who created this
product
specifically to circumvent regulations
specifically
to circumvent federal and international
overreach so
part of the reason i'm i love crypto so
much is is
it is more than a tangible blockchain
is the future of technology when you
talk about ethereum don't think of
ethereum as a coiner as a token
think of it as the world wide web in
1980.
it it's it's a blockchain a system
of of how you're going to create
interaction social interaction business
interaction if it's an infrastructure
right and i don't want to get like what
is starting to happen though is
ethereum's starting to get more momentum
than
like amongst a lot of experts people are
highlighting what ethereum does that's a
lot more advanced technology wise
and usage-wise long-term than bitcoin
long term
you think in ethereum i'm not saying i'm
just saying what experts are saying look
at what you have to
look at what you have to do to close on
your house everything that you talked
about the days that you
what you have to do the money in escrow
the payments that you have to make the
proof of purchase that you have to have
then the documents that you have to sign
all of that
now becomes one token with ethereum you
pay
for a house with ethereum and the
contract is on the token
it's all there so it doesn't seem like a
lot to people
but what's a day of your time worth at
this point what's like what is your
worth
in a day so if if ethereum can save you
an entire day what is that worth to you
as opposed to
traditional signing of documents and
then who knows
couldn't this be forged i mean this is
antiquated we are we're horse and buggy
right now
this is this is analog ethereum is the
future man like there's so
there's so much beyond the the spec the
the the
the speculative investing it's fun it's
gambling it's cool and it's new
but the technology is gaming but i'm
going to tell you something here so
so here's here's the real argument when
you think about this the fact that dalio
was saying it
i think dalio is hedging himself
on one end he's saying this could happen
regulation could took place on the other
hand he's saying
it could not happen meaning if it's not
going to happen guess what i'm going to
also buy some stock buying a
put or a call you're buying like options
against you know you're kind of
leveraging whatever you're buying to
protect yourself whatever maybe you're
playing
you're playing playing both sides but by
the way never has dahlia come up and
said he's playing both sides he's just
never said that
so the fact that a guy as brilliant as
him i've sat down with him i've had
great conversations with him
the guy is brilliant as him to say i
have some bitcoin
he's not saying that without some
motive behind it for his investors to be
paying attention he knows it's going to
be written about
in every other paper so there's a hint
he's given he went until it was half
price
he bought enough of it i think he's
smart for doing it but i will take this
other part i will tell you this other
part
this other thing to be thinking about
with the wall street beds look at wall
street bets right they went up against
two
everybody yeah everybody and they ruined
a lot of these guys melvin melvin
capital specifically destroyed them
what 2.75 billion dollars that was a
seven seven billion
it's just it's a massive number to the
point where they have to go borrow money
from each other
and they closed all their short
positions that's that they call so so
to me the community of wall street bets
is the crypto community
okay and the government the regulators
the janet yellens of the world those
elizabeth warrens of the world they're
the
these big hedge fund managers that wall
street bets went up against
you have to know that when that took
place thank you thanks babe
when that took place you have to know
not you babe thanks to my wife i know
that sounds good sam is walking away
he just called me babe my wife gave it
to you you gave it to me so thanks babe
slash
sam okay thanks bad so sam walked away
saying pat call me babe
but uh hr yeah but but the way i see
this the way i see this
these billionaires they have to make one
phone call and they just have to say
i just want you know remember that
campaign i gave you what was that all
about
you can't let this happen again so that
part there's go
you think chris understand the tech you
really don't they're they're
you think crony capitalism is going away
any time no i know but it's specifically
you're right but this stuff is
specifically set up to
counteract oh i get that i get that so i
it's
i do that and this this could be ageism
you know and these are some of the
smartest people in the world get don't
get me wrong
but they don't understand the technology
i don't disagree warren buffett has
straight up said
i don't invest what i don't understand
that's even more of a reason why i
believe scares the hell out of them
absolutely that's what i'm saying they
don't get it the fact that it scares the
hell out of them they're like hey listen
this is too much slow down what do we
need to do like
you know what what is the card we can
always pull out regulation
put some regulation on it go out and
regulate them that's you know what this
is right here what's that
time baby it's undefeated they can be as
rich as they want
their time's running out it's not time
though listen there are certain
okay so i was in a health insurance
business 18 years ago 19 years ago
selling health net selling you know blue
cross blue shield health insurance okay
and health insurance is actually good
business to be a part of 20 years ago
here's how it works so if let's just say
you have a book of business there was
guys that was making half a million
dollars a year golfing five days a week
why because once you build a block of
business
you were making 10 10 every month
off the premium so if you're paying a
thousand dollars a month for your
family's premium guess what i'm making
what
a hundred bucks but it's hundred bucks
every month so
ten years later you build a block of
business you're making thirty forty
fifty thousand dollars every single
month
and then comes out what obamacare when
obamacare
comes out guess what happens obamacare
now says
here's what we're doing here's the plans
that we have and then you have free
enterprise competing against the
government right for contract
they can do whatever they can to make
new laws and regulations to hurt
everybody else
when you directly compete with the
government the government has a card
you don't have that card is we create
the rules
you play by our rules and the government
what they specifically don't like
is the following they don't like people
like elon musk
they don't like people like trump they
don't like the crypto community you know
why because they're going like this
saying hey absolutely
screw you and they don't like when
people say screw you
they like when people say we need you
world wouldn't be the same without you
thank you so much oh my gosh the hunger
games syndrome yeah
you're so whole they bow down to you so
the crypto community is not bound down
to anybody yeah some dogs like their
leash yeah sure that's that part anyways
we'll see what's gonna happen here
to wrap this up with to put a bow on
this with our friend dalio he came
out what was the famous thing that he
said in davos switzerland you know a
year and a half ago right before corona
hit he goes cash is trash
get the hell out of cash yeah he did see
so i would not be surprised if he
you know diversified his investments and
got out of cash and bought some crypto
or some bitcoin even though he might not
be a firm believer in it
we know that he's not a believer in
necessarily cash and that timing
couldn't have come worse for him but
by the way i agree so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye